I was tested for Hashimoto's about 27 years ago and had the antibody. So Hashimoto's is when
you develop antibodies to the thyroid globulin cells so you got thyroid globulin antibodies
or thyroid globulin proxidase cells which are TPO antibodies. So those are two different antibodies
that you would test in a person's blood and if they were elevated you have Hashimoto's.
Well you have either Hashimoto's or Graves' disease. So if you have spike T3
be strongly elevated T3 with elevated TPO or thyroid globulin antibodies then you have
Graves' disease. If you have normal or low T3 then you have Hashimoto's. So it's very
common in Hashimoto's. So I hadn't been tested again until last May or did not have any antibodies.
The doctor told me that I either never had it or I had it under control very well.
Just recently I read that if you have cancer diagnosis these antibodies don't show up as this truth.
No, I don't think that's true. I've never read anything about that. If you have your Hashimoto's
under control your antibodies can go back down to normal. So if you ever had elevated antibodies you
definitely had Hashimoto's. But remember autoimmune disease is diagnosed in three phases. So if you
have elevated antibodies but you don't have any really bad symptoms so you just shows up on
blood work meaning so if you're diagnosing autoimmune disease shown up on blood work or you don't have
any bad symptoms or you don't have any tissue destruction that's in what's called silent autoimmunity
or phase one stage one autoimmunity and that's probably what you were in. And you know you can get
that under control and you can put it in remission. So you can cure an autoimmune disease but you can
put it in remission for a long, long time. So that's probably what's going on. You know you
when you were diagnosed with cancer you made a lot of dietary changes you made different lifestyle
changes and that can really calm down an autoimmune disease too. So that's good news.